sick tired hungry desperate these are
the latest rahega arrivals they've been
running for months and it's taken its
toll this the world's biggest refugee
camp will be their new home but after
escaping company more danger looms
deadly rains bringing flash floods and
landslides it's hard to overstate the
problems that could face this camp come
monsoon if you have a look at this slope
it's a perfect example of how steep they
are you can see here that the earth is
already loose if you just add rain all
of it will go tumbling down the hillside
bringing with it the houses and people
as well that Basin would fill with water
in a day of rain imagine the problems
after four months and on top of that
you've got issues like disease as well
an aid agencies here saying it's not if
people will die it's really a matter of
how many you know all this water is
gonna rise so you know I mean these all
these houses here you know they'll have
to go they'll have to move them at least
20% of this camp is at risk and there
are just a few weeks left to make people
safe people are calling this the
emergency within the emergency the
numbers are staggering as you say you
know it's a hundred thousand people out
of five hundred sixty thousand people
who will be directly impacted from the
flooding and the landslides but don't
forget fire is a huge risk
don't forget communicable diseases is
still a risk
in cramped conditions disease spreads
fast thousands have already caught
diphtheria and doctors fear there's
worse to come
the monsoon in Bangladesh this area
cholera diarrhea it is very common okay
and other waterborne diseases like
typhoid fever you can say we have to be
think about those problems now so you
worried
these are among the poorest people on
earth
everyone here relies on aid but disease
floods and storms now bring new threats
to the rahega a group who've already
survived so much
Siobhan Robbins Sky News Bangladesh